the science says our students can't go
back to their normal routine
therefore i am suspending in-person
learning in schools for the remainder of
the 2019-2020
school year we're going to have the
schools remain closed for the rest of
the year they must begin
the school year this fall
through distance learning now we have a
tendency as humans and as americans who
live such fast-paced lives
to want to move on too fast from crises
now what do i mean by that
isn't the resilient approach of carrying
on a good thing laura a trait to be
encouraged rather than crying over
spilled milk
when we're talking though about
something as profoundly damaging as the
government's pandemic lockdown mandates
the answer is yes and no
no we shouldn't wallow in all the
lingering miseries that we can't change
but yes
we need accountability to ensure that
this never ever happens again
and that means holding accountable
anyone in any organization that
recklessly pushed policies that were
never grounded in science and certainly
not permissible under our constitution
now almost immediately when the
lockdowns began on a federal level and
then trickling into the states the angle
was a relentless force for protecting
the vulnerable and also for reopening
the government and especially the
schools
there are devastating consequences of
keeping children away from school for
extended periods of time from a medical
and a common sense standpoint the
decision to put kids back in school
should be a slam dunk yes they don't do
well at all without in-person schooling
the damage incalculable academic decline
depression isolation suicide addiction
abuse
now we tried to warn blue states that
keeping the schools closed to in-person
learning and shutting down the athletics
remember that all the gems
that that was going to come back to bite
him
and we were right
politically speaking the virginia
governor's race that san francisco
school board wiped out of the democrats
the dfw races earlier this week
all point to coming huge losses of
pro-closure democrats in november
and now more than two years later
democrats who advocated for the closures
social distance learning all that stuff
they're seeing the fallout for
themselves
two left-leaning media outlets published
opinion pieces today admitting in stark
terms the horrible and lingering effects
of the lockdowns on our young people
mary katherine hamm writing in cnn noted
that much of blue america which kept
clues schools remote or hybrid for 2020
2021 conducted an unprecedented social
experiment on children resorting to
lengthy school closures for millions a
tactic not used during other national
emergencies or previous pandemics well
now the results are in from the social
experiment and they're very very bad and
the people who supported closures are
finally ready to talk about it
she cited david leonard's new york times
report that the main effects of hybrid
and remote instruction are negative
implying that even at low poverty high
income schools students fell behind
growth expectations when their schools
went remote or hybrid
but the the consequences were even worse
for lower income schools
and speaking of the times an even more
chilling examination of how this is now
manifesting itself at colleges and
universities
you got disengaged students they're
performing poorly many are not even
showing up regularly and on time for
in-person classes
when classes return mainly in person in
the fall of 2021 student performance
didn't bounce back the problem isn't
only that students learn poorly online
it's also that when they go through a
year or more of remote classes they
develop habits that harm their ability
to learn offline too
now meanwhile while this zombie
phenomenon appeared at many of the elite
top-tier schools that stayed close to in
person
one small catholic college in texas was
faring really well
the university of dallas
kids were back in school in the fall of
2020 and they were pretty much on track
and they were engaged and they were
doing what they were supposed to be
doing which is learning it's pretty
common sense
one professor there described their
thinking this way
they balance the immediate health
imperative with other imperatives that
are no less important the importance of
mental health the importance of
friendship the importance of physical
proximity to other human beings for most
of us
if only the teachers union captive
politicians if only they had possessed
such wisdom
instead for them it was all about
political allegiance and payback
heck congress the house representatives
are still back uh not back in session
pelosi is still allowing house members
to vote remotely and just today she once
again extended that pandemic proxy
voting rules through the period of june
28th it's never going to end
indeed much of the federal workforce
across every department across every
agency it's still not back in office
this is a complete
scandal
a dereliction of duty and it's the
ultimate bleep you to the american
taxpayers
now some members of congress are trying
to force the employees of the federal
government back to the same work roles
that they had in december 2019
like andy biggs with his return to work
act
naturally federal workers you know look
they just want to stay home just like so
many of the teachers did before they
were forced back into the classroom
but students suffered
and now taxpayers are suffering as well
the federal employees union though they
don't care just like randy weingarten's
aft didn't care even though now she's
pretending to
our kids are in crisis
and we had a mental health
crisis
before kovid
but for two years of disruption
two years of looking at the screens two
years of not having a normal kind of
routine and rhythm
recovery is really tough okay i'm
throwing something at the screen okay i
can't believe it
is she kidding me
you're responsible for that sweetie
if staying at home is what pro-union
democrats prefer though i have good news
for many of them voters are going to be
sending you home permanently come
november
it's on its way and it's essential
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else